hi sal um so tell us a little bit about
your book and the journey that that you
underwent before you started the khan
academy which led you to writing this
book yeah well the book is well it's
it's it's a little bit about that
journey but really how that journey kind
of informed what khan academy has now
become and then how that could inform
what maybe
classrooms could become or what learning
could become and not in just a kind of a
pie in the sky kind of way but i know
this is really happening and it really
feels like we're at this kind of this
this inflection point and what's going
on in in classrooms uh you know this
whole
adventure for me started somewhat
actually very inadvertently it was uh
2004 i was uh i was working as an
analyst at a hedge fund at the time
just gotten married family from new
orleans visiting me in boston after my
wedding and uh it turned out this one
cousin nadia was was having trouble 12
years old
i had trouble believing that you know
she
extremely bright girl um
we shared a certain amount of dna too
and and
and uh and when i when i asked her about
actually her mom who told me and i asked
nadia about it and she said oh yeah i'm
having trouble with units and and i said
well you know
you you let me tutor you and and i think
she thought i was just bluffing so i
said no we're gonna work this out so she
went back to new orleans got on the
phone we ended up using some tools on
the internet so that we could see each
other's scrolls initially with a mouse
and then we got these little pen tablet
things
and uh
long story short it you know she went
from being a struggling student to
catching up with their class and then
becoming a somewhat advanced uh a
student actually i joke i became a tiger
cousin at that point i called her school
and i said you know i really think nadia
needs to be in the retake a placement
exam and they said who are you i said
i'm her cousin
but but uh you know i then i started
tutoring her brothers and uh fast
forward two years word got around free
tutoring was happening i was tutoring 10
15 family friends cousins and it was at
that point that a um
and the firm i was working for
it was a firm but it was my boss and his
dog and me we we moved to silicon valley
and uh i was showing i was telling a
friend about all the stuff i was doing
with my cousins and he said well and i
was complaining that it was getting hard
to scale i still had a day job you know
all these students around the country
with time zones and et cetera et cetera
and he said well why don't you make
some tutorials stick them up on on on
youtube
and uh i thought that was a silly idea
youtube's for cats playing piano not not
serious
um but uh i i gave it a shot and you
know long story short that kind of
started getting a ton of traction people
started looking at it uh in those days i
also was working on this little software
tool for my cousins and so there was
this view that hey maybe this could be
an institution to help people and so the
setup is a not-for-profit and then in
2009 i had trouble focusing on my day
job so
quit and started doing kind of academy
full time well so tell me a little bit
about the khan academy what is the
business model let's start with the the
big hairy audacious goal which i just
found very big and audacious and then
the business model that that you're
you've based it on yeah so the the well
maybe i'll go the other way around
because you know
when i was starting all of this and i
was sitting in the middle of silicon
valley i came from a very for-profit
reality right um there were i had
friends who were venture capitalists
says hey sal let's you know we could
fund this and it could be this double
bottom line business or whatever that
means and um and there was a lot of
temptation there and there's nothing
wrong with that but there was this this
feeling you know i was getting all this
emotional reward from these thank you
letters that people were sending me and
the sense that hey i was making these
simple things for my cousin and now you
know at first tens of thousands hundreds
thousands now millions of students are
using it around the world
i'd like this stuff to be around in 100
years or in 500 years and i don't want
this
you know this collection of software and
content and
this organization i don't want it to
skew from this mission of of being able
to reach these people and so
you know when i look at other
organizations in the universe that are
able to do that last
many many hopefully centuries
and stay true to a mission it's a
not-for-profit where there is no
ownership it's it's a public it's a
public charity and uh and so i said well
i should set this up as a not-for-profit
not quite understanding what that is and
i remember when i was doing that initial
paperwork for it the irs asks you you
know what's your mission
and i kind of thought about it for maybe
three or four minutes and i said well
you know a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere
why not well you know you never want
something that you can just say check
it's done it's an aspiration
and it was a very delusional aspiration
at the time i was literally operating
out of a closet uh but but yeah and and
so the business model is we're not a
business we're a
501c3 not-for-profit but we still have
to sustain ourselves
and the way we want to because we always
want the learning side of education we
always want that to be free because we
think that's what empowers people
it's primarily foundation and
philanthropist driven so far but we we
do think there are ways to
to sustain itself in other ways whether
it's licensing content or who knows what
we're we're we're starting to explore
that but we're pretty true to keeping
the content free sure so how many
students are you serving right now how
many instructors can you give me a sense
as to how large
yeah of an enterprise so what's the
typical profile of someone who comes to
your website yeah so those are so so the
organization itself for 36 people so
we're still relatively small but for us
it feels huge for me because last year
we were 13 and a year before that we
were one so we've been growing yeah
we've been growing fast but uh in this
past month we've reached 7 million
students unique students
we've reached a total of 60 million
unique as the way you measure unique
students on the web uh delivered 180
million lessons 700 million problems
have been done on the site and it's you
know it's it's students all over the
world it's uh pretty much every country
in the world has
someone has has used the khan academy in
some way uh 20 000 teachers
as far as we can tell from our data are
using it uh with in in their classes or
with their cohorts in in in some type of
way so it's it's it's it's kind of crazy
not called it's surreal for uh
where it came from
yeah so let's talk a little bit about
how a classroom or a school can use you
with this concept of a flipped classroom
um explain that to our viewers yeah and
i'll i'll do two things because this
flipped classroom has somewhat been tied
to khan academy and it is an interesting
idea and it is i think a forward step
but part of the whole point of this
whole book was to show people you know
we're not necessarily about this flip
we're actually about pushing the
envelope even further than the flip so
in a flip model you know right now at
home you do problems traditionally
that's called homework and in the
classroom a lot of time in a traditional
classroom is spent lectures and the the
flip is and it predates khan academy
early on i had these videos out there
some teachers were telling me hey you
made a decent video on meiosis or on you
know projectile motion i don't have to
give that lecture anymore my students
can watch it at their own time and pace
they can remediate without you know
taking up class time and then when they
go to class that's when they can either
ask me questions clarifications and we
can do problems together so it used to
be homework the the problem sets could
now be done inside the classroom and and
the advantage there is the real learning
occurs when you do the engagement when
you're doing the problem sets and i
think traditionally students either
don't do homework or have trouble doing
homework because there's no one at home
to help them out now they're in the
classroom they have the teacher they
have their peers which is an under
utilized resource in the classroom not
only to help you but when you help
others you learn a lot better and
and it also gives the teacher a lens on
how the class is doing when you're
lecturing it's very hard to know
where people are i mean you might be
able to pull them ask a few questions
but it's very hard a lot of times the
students are a little bit you know blank
faces but now if you're doing problem
solving together you can do much more uh
uh you can understand where students are
and diagnose them and so that's the flip
uh it's what used to be homework in the
classroom what used to be
lectures are now at home
it makes the classroom interactive
students can get lectures at their time
and pace
great
what what i i focus on a lot in the book
is let's go even further because still
even the flip
assumes that all the students are going
to cover the same material at the same
pace together and what i talk a lot
about is this you know we've all been
indoctrinated in in the system
and when i talk about the system i'm not
talking about you know what should be
the student teacher ratio or what you
know charter or private or public i'm
talking about the system i'm talking
about grouping kids by age-based cohorts
they cover certain subjects at a set
pace
we grade them based on their variable
understanding and then we keep pushing
them forward and we just assume that's
what school is
but what what i go through great lengths
to show is no this is actually a
relatively new phenomena it's about 200
years it's not that new it's 200 200
years old but we we inherited from uh a
country that no longer exists the the
the the
the prussians and you know in fairness
to the prussians and and even to
to us i guess
you know it was
this during the industrial revolution
was the first time that people seriously
thought about how can we educate
everybody before that it was you know
you're the son of a you know a lord and
you would get a king and you'd get a
private tutor and and the private
shooter was the gold standard it was you
know they're they're working at your
pace they're differentiating it for you
but now all of a sudden you're in
prussia there's like okay we want to
have mass education how do we do it in
in a in a practical way and say well
it's the industrial revolution well how
do we do anything in a practical way we
stick them on an assembly line and as
they go through we kind of do something
to the product and then hopefully at the
end we have a decent product and so they
essentially applied the same model to
classrooms the kids are in these buckets
based on age you know it's funny i was
talking to a friend and her child is
already knows how to read and everything
and she was trying to get the child into
kindergarten you know he was like born
in october or something and and um
and and the school said oh yeah he's
very bright kid but you know we can't
he's he's too small
and i told my friend she came back he's
like yeah he's too small i was like look
if that's what they were concerned about
they should be grouping them by size
right
this is the obvious natural uh but but
so that's the model and so what and even
the flip is in the context of that model
you have you know on week three we cover
parabolas week four we cover systems of
equations and even if you have a we give
students grades we call them we give
them a b and that b shows that they have
a gap in their knowledge a c even a d
you can get an exam but then you move to
the next topic that's usually building
on top of that which is pretty much
dooming you to failure exactly and so
what i advocate strongly and we're
already seeing this in school starting
to experiment or move in this direction
is
if you take lecture out of the classroom
there's no longer the need for everyone
to move together at the same pace and as
soon as you make get rid of that
assumption you can completely rethink
what a classroom can be you can start
having everyone learn at their own pace
you can leverage class time when humans
are together for actual interactivity
you can start to say well why do we only
have one teacher in the room why can't
we have two teachers in the room why do
we have a bell ring and this bell
ringing this is like a factory and you
know right you know in a 19th century
factory why do we have a bell ringing
that's saying stop what you're doing on
chemistry you must now start english
and we all know anyone who's done
anything creative is that's the best way
to stop creativity right is to say you
have exactly 55 minutes and then you're
done and so
what
what we're advocating is move to reality
with possibly with the help of tools
like khan academy so that every student
can learn at their own pace teachers
have dashboards tools that empower them
and that use class time for
interactivity and creativity right right
um you touched on this a little bit but
explain a little bit about why is it
that your platform has taken off and is
getting so much attention when so many
others who are kind of trying to do the
same thing on the for-profit side some
on the non-profit side haven't succeeded
yeah it's an open question and it's a
question that we we're constantly asking
ourselves because we don't whatever the
secret sauce is we don't want to lose it
somewhere in the process
my my best guess of why there was this
initial wave of traction um you know
from 2006 to 2000 and even you know it
continues to grow is those first videos
i think it was fortunate that it was
just some guy making it for his cousins
um i i think so they were easy to use
they were easy to use they felt very
human and i think the big learning is is
that people were hungry you know i
wasn't the first person to make videos
on youtube i wasn't the first person to
think of teaching you know as soon as
radio came out people were saying oh
we'll use this to teach the world and
then tvo we'll use this to teach the
world and vcr now it's on demand
but
historically it was either a videotape
of someone at a chalkboard
you know traditional class yeah which
feels very it feels distant even when
you're in the classroom you know you're
there i'm over here the next step in the
equation and you do it like that right
and so that's very not very and when you
make that in the video it's even harder
to see you know what are they what are
they writing there and i can't hear them
um and and these felt very personal they
uh you're sitting next to me i think the
the other the other dimension of it is
just the conversational tone
it's you know i think a lot of people
they they they try to make it very
polished which is which is not bad but
in that process you lose the humanity so
it sounds like your gps system you know
the next step in this equation is when
and uh
and i think hopefully i i this is
something that i try to put into it is
one of the things that i think allowed
me to do to to kind of thrive in in math
or science and eventually even finance
was i felt like i had a really holistic
understanding of things and my my basics
were really really really solid and then
you know my basics in algebra were
really good so when i went into calculus
i was like oh this is intuitive and when
i went into you know corporate finance i
was like this is intuitive there's
nothing new here and and and you see
other really really smart people
they're just learning for the next exam
memorizing formulas then they forget it
and then when they see a related concept
it's like what's this and so what i try
in those early days for my cousins is
give a sense of intuition draw the
connections between things so that when
they see this new concept it's not some
random new concept it's connected to
everything they learned before and and i
and i get a lot of letters and i i would
have assumed that that would have only
been appealing to you know the motivated
kids so to speak but i get a lot of
letters from kids that
were traditionally disengaged or
demotivated and they said that's why i
was demotivated no one was explaining
the why well no one was giving me the
connection so hopefully that that's why
people are have been i guess
connecting to the to the content yeah
so let's talk a little bit about virtual
education and offering the types of
things that you're offering a lot of
people are still a little wary of of
these reforms they see it as a mechanism
to ultimately get rid of teachers in the
classroom or reduce class sizes you talk
a little bit about this in the book and
explain that a little bit yeah yeah no i
think that's that's a super important
point because whenever you know when
we've learned in the last 15 20 years
with the internet whenever people see
virtual
robot it's like is that going to replace
the physical you know barnes and nobles
versus amazon.com there's a natural
contention there uh
that's the exact opposite of what i
think is going to happen in education
everything we do
is not going to replace a physical
school i have young kids i want them to
go to a physical school i want them to
get interaction what it will do is i
think
give
all of our children the experience that
i think every parent and every teacher
or every student wants to be a part of
is that even now we're going to physical
experience but we're not leveraging the
humans we're going and but for the most
part people are sitting passively there
and they're listening and it's hard for
the teachers too because you're not it's
it's it's hard to to just speak for for
60 minutes without getting that that
connection with the students and so what
we're advocating is
leverage tools so you can get maybe
information delivery out of the way so
you can get some of the problem solving
out of the way but so when people go and
they have class time the scarce class
time with other human beings then that's
optimally interactive and not
interactive in the web sense interactive
in the human sense so class time is all
conversation class time is all
peer tutoring and working with the
teacher class time is all doing
open-ended projects and so
you know i i talk about this in the book
and i gave a ted talk a bunch you know
the irony here is
i strongly believe and it's not just
talk again you know we're seeing this in
classrooms is that
you can actually use technology to make
the classroom more human and i'm very
careful you know you mentioned their
skepticism i think there should be i'm
skeptical when someone says hey we just
ordered 500 ipads for our school and i
said well what are you going to do with
it or how are you going to integrate
into curriculum or how are you going to
leverage it to make to fundamentally
transform what's going on and there
usually aren't a lot of answers there
and so i think it is good to be
skeptical but at the same time there is
i think a reason reason reason for hope
and so how do you evaluate the impact of
your courses since again you talk a
little bit about grades in your book and
how you don't like the concept of
grading how do you know that they have
actually worked yeah and and i'll i'll
tell you i mean a lot of times when i
grew up i remember i sometimes would
meet people so i don't believe in grades
and i thought they were these kind of
like you know granola bar hippie type
people that you know
and now i think i appreciate what they
were saying
grades you know normally when you say
people people who don't like grades you
really think that they're being
touchy-feely they're not being rigorous
but actually they're being they're
saying grades aren't rigorous enough
grades are this thing that give this
feeling of rigor oh a b as oh you really
know your stuff f you don't know your
stuff
one they're they're somewhat arbitrary
you know depends on the test depends on
how it's measured
but but even more than that when you
give grades especially in the sense if
you if you got a c on an exam you have
obvious weaknesses assuming that it was
even a good exam you have obvious
weaknesses
and so that should be used as an
assessment to say okay you need to now
improve on those weaknesses before we
move on to a more advanced topic look
it's common sense get your basics down
but instead we use grades as a value
judgment you're smart you're dumb you're
fast you're slow and that's that's a
that's just going to be a
self-fulfilling prophecy so what we say
is no let's just make sure everyone
masters every concept so rather than
having a superficial understanding of
algebra and then moving over onto
trigonometry make sure you really
understand algebra deeply and then
trigonometry is going to make a lot more
sense it's going to be a lot easier to
learn and if you master trigonometry
then calculus is going to start seeing
seeing is seeming very intuitive
in terms of
how we're doing it
we're working with schools in famously
los altos which is now using khan
academy you know it's probably one of
the best if not the best school district
in the country is is using khan academy
uh for fifth through eighth grade
as part of their as one of the tools
that they use and there we have formal
studies going on to understand exactly
how this is impacting students and
teachers both
objectively on things like test scores
and grades but also on things on on on
subjectively are the teachers more
excited about their work are the
students more excited about about their
work and then on top of that you know we
have
three million problems done a day on our
site we have this huge number of
students seven million a month using our
site so we have this this treasure trove
of data on our site itself and so we are
building an analytics deal
yeah i mean all the stuff that all these
other web companies are able to do we as
a kind of education not-for-profit can
now do using analytics
optimizing for engagement seeing what
kind of learning is going on great great
so
tell me a little bit about so you you
gave a great historical overview of how
we came to educate students today the
way we're educating them did you
always hold these views and know this
information before you stumbled on the
khan academy or the
this platform that you created or were
these things that you you know studied
afterwards it just so happens that
everything flows so beautiful inside
it's it's fine i am i was curious as to
what came first you know it
it's been a combination i actually think
it's more of the latter
you know obviously all of us have spent
a lot of time in the system
i think the whole time you know anybody
who knew me growing up i mean they knew
that i was always like why is this this
way why is this that way wait why why
can't i tutor you know i used to get
reprimanded for trying to tutor my i
know what this this is this would have
been a really positive interaction and
so there's this question you know when
you go to college and you're like wow
people are sitting in this lecture hall
is anything really happening in here it
seems like all the learning is happening
when they're the cram session you know
three days before the final and and so
there's always these ideas and then
obviously when i started working with my
cousins i started seeing that my cousins
were were motivated they were for the
most part good students but they were
having these huge gaps in their
knowledge they weren't learning things
intuitively called swiss cheese swiss
cheese learning et cetera and so
i in very pragmatic way started building
these tools and it was really a process
of discovery of teachers emailing me
saying hey we're using it this way we're
using it that way and so it's a
combination of these instincts of like
well how did i learn how do other people
i know who learn things holistically how
did they learn what am i seeing with my
teacher with with my uh with my cousins
what are teachers telling me and then
it's kind of academy got more and more
traction i started having people tell me
about a lot of the stuff i mean i knew a
little bit about the history before you
know i'd heard about this whole you know
committee of 10 and 18 you know someone
had told me about that in high school um
but but it was interesting that and you
know even the research i the original
reason why i made the video so short is
because youtube limited me to 10 minutes
but then
i used to have researchers telling me no
there's actually cognitive research that
shows and that's what you know that's
where a lot of that research from the
book comes from that like actually
people for especially dense academic
content can't pay attention for more
than 10 to 15 minutes and so it starts
as wow so why are we doing these you
know why are we using class time this
time with human beings for these hour
long lectures or sometimes 90 minute
lectures can't we get people to interact
more and you know the more i did
research a lot of these kind of just
basic common sense ideas gelled with
research and that's when you feel best
about it because they are common you
know every it
it's weird when research tells you
something very non-intuitive but here
it's telling you something very very
very intuitive and the only the only
kind of hard to grasp thing is that
we're indoctrinated into a strange model
right right now it all makes sense um so
tell me a little bit about your own
education i mean something despite the
regimented system that you grew up in
something must have gone right was it a
teacher was it your parents you think
who kind of
built this sense of inquisitiveness and
um
or was it yeah was did you go to a
particular type of school that was open
to nurturing you as an individual and
paying attention to your specific needs
um or
yeah that none of these things work yeah
no no no i mean i i i i'd be delusional
although i am sometimes delusional if i
would say that if none of that stuff
played in i mean i think there were
probably two i mean there's probably a
bunch of different factors and i'm
probably forgetting some of them one i
was blessed to have an older sister who
was a very good student so i think that
projected when i would walk into a
classroom the teachers would remember my
sister and say oh you're a pharah sister
you're fairest brother you must be and i
was like you know i was like in speech
therapy and stuff
but they would they would project that
and you know there's actually now
studies that show that that projection
has huge implications for your own
self-esteem so that was
luck uh on top of that i you know i went
to a just a i would say it was a public
school in jefferson parish public
schools in jefferson parish right
outside of new orleans
i would say it was the average american
public schools all of them you know
middle elementary middle and high school
but
you know
there were some incredible teachers
there i think in um in high school in
particular mr hernandez miss kennedy ms
kennedy was a journalism teacher and
actually i would say that's where a lot
of the ideas that look class should not
be a lecture class should be working
alongside the teacher it was a
journalism class so we would we had a
product a creative product a newspaper
to work on i was the art editor and she
would give us feedback and she was like
our senior peer and i remember those
interactions a lot of the experience
that i got from journalism i still think
about when i'm when i'm when i'm working
on khan academy
i think early in my schooling i think
this was key and also lucky
i i got into you know i don't know what
they call it now these gt programs and
what they did is you know you have this
very structured prussian curriculum for
most of the day but then one day a week
they take you out of a different
classroom and they take you into these
gt classrooms and there you go into this
classroom which is essentially the kind
of classroom that i ideally everyone
should have where you have this really
it was actually mr cell and miss krauss
these two teachers and they you know
they had phds in education and and they
i remember the first day walking into gt
and
miss russell said so what do you want to
do
and i was like eight
and i was like
i like to draw and then she says well
you should draw more then and then but
you would introduce me to these things
different styles different tools to draw
what else are you interested in and i
was like i like puzzles
and she's like well here's some puzzles
and she would give me these brain
teasers but and so she was mentoring me
and it was self-paced and i was able to
go to my own pace and there was other
kids working on interesting things and i
would get inspired by them sometimes we
would work on things and i think we
needed that breathing room to have
i i wonder if i didn't have that
experience early on in my life
whether i would have had the ability to
kind of
self-direct or had the ability to kind
of say oh look let me solve that problem
no you know that's an interesting thing
to tackle right so along those lines do
you have any advice for parents out
there you know first graders second
graders and i'm asking you this because
in your book you also highlight how a
lot of students in southeast asia
go to school in order to show off what
they know not necessarily to learn in
school so are there habits that you
think parents can
start to you know put in place early on
despite how the schools are approaching
education yeah and you know take
everything i see with a grain of salt i
have a three-year-old and a one-year-old
so maybe i should be getting advice from
the parents of seven or eight-year-olds
i'm trying to get my one-year-old off of
a pacifier well now that you know ipads
are very yeah no no you're absolutely
you're absolutely right i mean
my sense having kind of gone through the
system and even we're observing we're
working with a lot of teachers we're
working a lot of schools now
i would say there's a couple of
dimensions here i think it is true uh
asians whether it's east asian south
asian
they
there is a culture of
school is where you go to show what
you've already learned at home and i
think that gives those students an
advantage of having this kind of
buffer of
their learning stuff maybe ahead and i'm
not saying that necessarily has to be
the way but that is a way to ensure that
your student in the prussian model
doesn't get you know falls behind and as
soon as they fall behind all of these
negative kind of self-perception things
and they start to reinforce each other
so so i i would do i mean i'll tell you
what i
would do with my own children i would do
some combination of
engaging them with a lot of the content
in a way before it becomes stressful so
you teach it when you tutor when i was
teaching a nadia algebra when she was in
algebra class it was stressful for her
because she's like i need to catch up i
have an exam on it
when i started teaching algebra to her
younger brother who's in fifth grade he
thought it was fun because there's no
stress here it was just a fun thing his
cousin was teaching so at least expose
your kids to the ideas and algebra and
physics and biology and chemistry early
on so that when they see it in school
they've already they've already had some
exposure the other thing i would say is
don't over schedule them i mean i think
sometimes the same parents that would
you know
the same parents that would do the
teaching ahead of time at the same time
will also you know you have piano
lessons you have soccer lessons you have
everything and i think
there's a value there definitely but if
it's complete over scheduling you have
the loss of time for the child to
develop their own creativity kind of
what i had in that gt class so you know
frankly you know the in the 80s i was a
latchkey child where you know my mom was
you know she worked these odd jobs and
would come home at six or seven o'clock
and so me and my sister would just hang
out and yeah some of it was wasted
watching tv but a lot of it was just
like i want to build something or i want
to draw or we would like make make up
games and stuff like that and kids need
that they need that free space and maybe
if they're blowing it all on video games
or watching tv you need to push them a
little bit to or or do something
creative with them right but they need
that time for creativity and the last
thing i would actually recommend is that
the parents themselves engage in
learning because
you set that example if you're 40 or 50
years old and you're going back and
learning algebra or cosmology or english
lit it's a huge signal for students
right so let's talk about your vision
for the ideal classroom or the this
futuristic vision that you outline here
about what the school of tomorrow should
look like which is a lifelong learning
approach to education i mean you also
talk about the college of tomorrow to
look like i was fascinated by this but
let's talk just about schooling you know
your notions of class size the ideal
classroom could potentially have a
hundred
students in it with four instructors
roaming around and helping students you
talked a little bit about grades already
but testing this is one of those topics
that comes up a lot here in washington
and with the discussions on capitol hill
but yeah how would you
you know describe that vision for us and
you also talk about how you would get
rid of summer vacations which is not
going to be popular but um yeah let's
dive into this a bit yeah no there's a
lot there i mean you know the first
dimension is
once you remove lecture from class time
you say class time is a time for
interaction you can have students
working at their own pace
allows you to rethink everything and so
a lot of the concepts in this book and a
lot of these are happening i mean there
are schools that we're working with that
are doing these things
these are they're they are experiments
but they're experiments that all the
research and all of the intuition point
in that direction teaching is for the
most part a solitary profession you're
the only teacher in the room
it's lonely it's lonely and and so
you could have 100 students you're not
changing the student teacher ratio you
might even improve it but you now have
four teachers in the same room now if
one of them gets sick students don't
have a substitute teacher different
students are going to connect with
different teachers they can mentor each
other they can do group things with
teachers together so there's a whole
dimension that you can add you could
have a physics teacher a math teacher a
chemistry teacher and a biology teacher
all teaching simultaneously so students
understand that all these sciences and
these math actually blend together
they're not these like siloed subjects
so they get holistic understanding you
know the tests themselves
you need some aspect of testing but
someone should be you should be very
skeptical of testing because all tests
measure
what they test
and and there's many more facets to to a
human being than that and so
the dimensions that you know there could
be some testing to make sure that
students are getting core competency and
some core skills but the more important
skills which i think are are completely
unmeasured right now are creativity and
you can never give someone a creativity
score but you can have someone generate
generate a portfolio of creative works i
mean you know we
as an employer we're hiring engineers
and
when we get these people great gpas from
top schools in the country and we say so
what have you created that's what
engineering is building new things
and they haven't created anything
because they've been
on the treadmill the whole time just
trying to finish problem sets and
they're very very smart people and so
the ideal is is that students over their
careers can show what they've created
it's not like they write a paper it gets
graded and gets thrown away they write a
paper maybe it gets graded and then they
keep working on the paper they keep
developing it when they're 18 they have
a novel done they have a bunch of papers
on policy done that they can show people
this is my work they have computer
programs written they build robots
and on top of that and this is another
dimension that's completely missed uh in
in
the prussian model so to speak is
as
i think in any field the people you want
to work with the most are the people who
have deep subject matter expertise and
but are also always willing to help
others and they have that communication
and that ability to empathize
and
in our in our current system we make
everyone very focused on themselves what
are your grades are you going to pass a
test cram for the next exam and in the
model that we're describing we're
starting to see in a lot of schools
let's focus everyone on on each other so
yeah you go at your own pace you might
be racing ahead and that's great you're
stimulated you're engaged
but you also have a chance to re-engage
with some students who might be having
difficulty and there's two things one
you're going to be helping that student
but even better when you explain that
hopefully and you develop your your
ability to explain you'll learn the
material better and you'll learn to
communicate you'll learn to empathize
and that actually is measurable i mean
you can you can have students rate each
other you can have people write
assessments for each other oh you know
he understood the stuff but he was a
little bit you know he spoke a little
fast and you could develop that aspect
and so
i'd imagine the transcript of the future
and i say the future what i mean the
future is like actually now um is yeah
you would have your test scores your
test scores would actually show actual
competency it wouldn't be grades it
would be like yeah i understand algebra
and i've renewed it right i've renewed
that i know algebra well i know
cosmology i'm a writer here's and here's
my writings
you have a portfolio of your creative
works in multi-dimensions
and you have reviews from people that
you've helped saying great person to
work with really understood the subject
matter really was able to communicate
well and those are the things that i
think anyone would actually care about
more than than just test scores right
but let's talk a little bit about what
happens in this classroom or school in
terms of subjects so you believe that so
right now they're you know you have to
take math you have to take uh english
language arts you know you start science
at a certain
point in time do you i mean do you
believe that all these basics should
also be thought in the school
and at what point i mean
another question i wanted to ask is i
mean do you believe that all children
can learn unless they have a serious
disability can they all progress to the
levels
that you have progressed to if they
simply learn and master
and show an interest really in the in
the subject matter that they are that
that they're studying and specifically
vis-a-vis the stem fields
science technology engineering and math
which are areas that kids tend not to
get interested in
is it just because they haven't mastered
it well and been pushed to understand it
early on or
are there limitations perhaps in how we
are currently trying to get students to
learn these subjects yeah so on the
latter question if you asked me 20 years
ago i said yeah maybe certain people are
predisposed to math and science and
other people aren't and and that made me
feel good because i was one of the
people who were predisposed it made me
feel like i i was meant to be there
wasn't luck but um my experience with my
cousins not the in particular but other
cousins and then what we're seeing in
schools you know the schools that are
kind of transitioning to this type of a
model where all the students are
learning at their own pace building
their foundations we're seeing you know
day five yeah some kids have raced to
head well those are the gifted kids and
some kids are falling behind you're like
oh maybe they need to be remediated and
a traditional model you would separate
them and you would actually tell these
kids you're smart you tell these kids
either explicitly or implicitly you're
not not as smart
but what we're seeing is if you keep
them together but you allow them to work
at their own pace so that they're
engaged they have mentorship from each
other and and the teacher
many times it's actually quite hard to
predict we're trying to predict it's
very hard
some of these students who are falling
behind maybe it's an algebra class and
they just some of them didn't know
multiplication well some of them didn't
know how to add fractions you give them
that opportunity to really build that
foundation on negative numbers
multiplication exponents whatever it
might be and then these kids race ahead
so it was not their problem wasn't that
they had some cognitive inability to
understand algebra the problem was
they're sitting in an algebra class and
for some reason they didn't understand
how to multiply or they didn't
understand how to add fractions and then
you're just going to feel silly in an
algebra class and you'll disengage
really just just to protect your own
self-esteem so i'm actually
now more and more convinced
that
pretty much everyone uh you know barring
certain exceptions could we don't know
where i mean we're still learning we
don't know but
progress far ahead and we're even seeing
it you know in these classrooms
we traditionally think motivated kids
maybe that's 20 of kids but as soon as
you allow people to engage and and fill
in gaps without feeling embarrassed you
start saying it's not 20 it's 80 or 90
of kids can start to to to feel engaged
uh in terms of
the first question about like what
subjects and how i i think it is an
interesting and i talk a little bit
about it is
you know it's the subjects that are
taught now are somewhat arbitrary they
were decided in 1892 by the committee of
10 mainly university you know male
university presidents who did not know
about you know this was before the
federal reserve existed the interstate
highways existed knowledge of dna and
you know a bunch of other stuff and they
decided that you know at age 14 you
should learn algebra at age 15 you
should learn geometry at age 16 you
should learn trigonometry so you should
learn physics your senior year in high
school you should learn i mean that's
when it was decided and it hasn't
changed since and i love all of those
subjects i think they're all fascinating
but i i i think there are obvious
questions you know should there be more
statistics statistics more valuable than
calculator at least is valuable um
should there be some knowledge of
economics who knows what it'd be i mean
i won't it's for society to decide but
the general idea is
at minimum it should be rethought within
the last 120 years there is grounds the
world has changed we should think more
about what these subjects are and and
even more i think you know and you
alluded to this should they even be
divvied up in these siloed subjects
these siloed subjects these are we're
indoctrinated into it so it's hard for
us to to break our minds from it this is
the factory model this is oh you're at
this you're at this machine in the
factory and so this is what will be
poured into the product okay now you're
gonna have the paint applied to you now
so now you're gonna have the chemistry
applied to you now you move on now
you're going and for some people that
might chip a little bit that's fine
that'll be a cheaper product at the end
but the reality is these i mean
chemistry is halfway in between
chem physics and biology and physics is
halfway in between chemistry and and
pure mathematics and all of them
actually have a an aspect of philosophy
to them all of them have an aspect of
aesthetics to them and
and whatever else and and writing can be
critical and logical thinking is is
across all programs you know you could
have something like
logic which is across everything and and
so i i think the reality we're moving to
is
yes you will show competency in things
say yeah i understand this domain well
so you can go take an exam and then
renew that exam to show that yes i still
understand that topic but while you're
in school someone might be preparation
for that particular
competency but most of the time we'll be
blending it where you're where you're
not you're not working to pass an
assessment you're working to create
things and so in the process of creating
things whether it might be a novel or a
robot or a business
you're integrating all of these things i
mean anyone who started a business if
sharing a tech business is there's a
comp there's art design there's
technology there's quantitative thinking
and there's writing and there's just
human skills and you need to integrate
that's what actually matters in the real
world and so
these when you break yourself from this
assembly line model you you give
yourself the freedom for people to
pursue these type of things
so why not create a khan academy charter
school or even a khan academy private
school
yes so
it's uh i'm sure you've thought of it at
least yes no i mean we go back and forth
on that but i um
it's
we're thinking about it uh we're
thinking about it i mean
where would you put it which country
would you pick to well for selfish
reasons i would probably put it in
mountain view california which would be
maybe walking distance from no but but
seriously i think
you know it's interesting because
and this shows the emphasis we put i
think a physical experience is
incredibly incredibly important you know
a lot of people in silicon valley say
well you're you're at scale already
you're reaching seven million and you're
growing you're doubling every year you
could reach 100 million students in five
years maybe a billion in your and you
know why are you even thinking about the
physical or why are you thinking about
physical schools and i always say well
that's because that's the core that's
and and i also think uh
you need you might say well why focus on
one school that might be able to reach a
few hundred kids when you're when you're
able to reach 100 million maybe one day
and and the idea is if you can show
examples of this and there are schools
that have already moved in that
direction los altos has moved in that
direction summit prep which is a charter
school they've broken down walls they
have multiple teachers teaching classes
in these kind of epic environments um
if you show examples of this then i
think that that's what moves that's what
moves the dial forward so how much would
be the tuition
the tuition would be you know
looking at avenues the new school in new
york forty thousand a child well you
know that that's the interesting thing
it was built without this book and a
vision behind it
a lot of markets well no the the money
is is fascinating you know education is
is you know someone asked me recently is
can you ever spend too much on education
and to some degree the answer is no i
mean it's such an important thing but at
the same time if you're going to spend
that much money you have to think
seriously about how you're spending it
and i've met with some you know
officials
about this and
public level charter
private schools and i just regardless of
school i say how much do you spend per
pupil per year if you ask a private
school some of them you know 25 000 30
000 40 000 a year you ask a public
school
you know the the some states it's as low
it goes down to five six thousand
dollars a year but most states
especially on the east coast it's ten
fifteen thousand new york city public
schools eighteen thousand a year
cambridge massachusetts twenty five
thousand dollars per year per student
and i say okay and what's your average
class size and they'll usually say some
number between 20 and 30.
i said okay private school you're
charging 30 000 a year that's 20
students that's 600 000 dollars per
classroom that's essentially for
the t you know what's directly impacting
the students the teacher the classrooms
and maybe the textbook
all i can figure out is maybe there's a
hundred thousand 150 000 being spent
there where's the other quarter of a
million or three hundred thousand
dollars same thing at any level
why can't we instead use
we can lower you know the private school
i think for ten thousand a year instead
of forty thousand ten thousand a year
you have twenty students or let's say
you have thirty students in a class
that's three hundred thousand dollars a
year i say pay the teacher 150 000 make
teaching you know a lot of people pay
lip service too oh we should you know
teaching should be on par with doctors
and engineers and lawyers i was oh yeah
that's a nice slip service but if you
really believe that pay teachers the
same as doctors engineers and lawyers
that's the best signal to society that
you actually value it and but the money
is clearly there and and then it'll have
to get cut from all the stuff that's not
impacting the students all of the i
don't know you know the i don't know
every time i ask this to people i just
do this back of the envelope calculation
this is what i used to do in my old
career i used to speak to cfos say oh
you're making this
what am i missing and the same exact
question
you know 15 000 a year times 30 students
is 450 000 a year the fully loaded cost
of the teacher is
less than half of that plus this where
where is that money going and and so i
think you could do a very good model for
what what public schools are spending
definitely some of the more you know the
schools the systems are spending ten
thousand dollars plus
um so talk a little bit about how um
bill gates came to discover you and and
i i just thought that chapter was so
interesting and yeah i mean what was it
like to to find out all of a sudden that
bill gates was watching your videos and
oh yeah what went through
i still wake up in the morning sometimes
wondering whether that was all like made
up or a dream
you know the site had already gotten
traction but in summer of 2010 one of
the our first donors andor um
sent me started telling me text messages
that bill gates was at the aspen ideas
festival
telling the whole audience that he uses
a
site that he thinks is great called the
khan academy and he uses it with his
kids and he uses it himself which made
me a little nervous because those videos
for nadia but then um you know hey and i
didn't know what to do i was like do i
reach out to him i mean i don't think
he's listed
he's uh um but then his uh two weeks
later chief of staff called and said you
know you might have heard bill bill's a
fan and i said i was like yeah yeah i
heard that and uh they they said you
know if you're free we'd like to fly you
up and i also get my calendars
completely blank
yeah i think i can make some time for
bill you know i've got to cut my nails
but other than that
my schedule's flexible and i i went up
and i mean really articulated this like
you know at the time it was mainly the
videos i was doing but i was like look
if we could get some resources and i was
dreaming about a five-person team in
some office space that was the dream at
that point um
we could make we could build out the
software that i started doing with my
cousins so students can get practice
they can get feedback we can start
building a community on the site so that
students can help each other we can
build dashboards for teachers so that
they could use it to diagnose students
and leverage class time more effectively
and and him and then a later google as
well uh you know they they were they
were strong believers in that great
um
so you know you talk a little bit about
um talent and creativity in your book um
and we talked a little bit about this
earlier on but do you think
you know in the advent of all these uh
not advent but since you know a couple
years ago there there were books focused
on talent talent is overrated the talent
code you name it so and i've read all of
them myself as i have a seven-year-old
who i'm trying to foster into a talented
individual do you think talent and
creativity are things that can be in
fact
you know taught to children or are they
i don't think they're i don't i i i'm
not sure and frankly i i and i think any
and i think anyone i i frankly i think
no one is sure uh i
my sense through both observation and
just even seeing what's happening there
is it it's not something that's taught
but it's something that can be untaught
it's not something that it's it's it's
not
and it's it's it can it can be fostered
or it can be suppressed
both talent and creativity and and i
actually think probably all i think
everyone is born with creativity i mean
there's not a two-year-old
on the planet who if you introduce a new
object into the room will not walk up to
that object and manipulate in every way
taste it feel it see what they can do
with it pour something there's not a
two-year-old on the planet there's not a
five-year-old actually most
five-year-olds will still a new object
in the room they will engage with it a
new idea they'll ask questions about it
but then something happens where they
they're taught to become more passive to
some degree they are an environment
where questioning is not always cool
they they're so overwhelmed with
work whether it's soccer practice or
homework that there's no time for them
to kind of just think about something
you know the class is moving on they
can't think about wait why am i why am i
carrying the one why does that make
sense it seems it's just like a formula
to me they don't have time for that type
of stuff and so
the you know all of these things fall
from this idea of just breaking from
this prussian model breaking from this
one-piece fit selector as soon as you
take that out now all of a sudden you
can start saying hey why can't we let a
student you know right now there's a if
there's a 16 year old someplace in the
country who has just some insight on
like well maybe cancer can be addressed
in maybe maybe this is what cancer is
and
too bad the clot the bell is going to
ring or they have an ap test the next
day or they have an exam like oh well
two i have too much work to do i have uh
you know there i quote an admissions
officer in the book talk about she was
interviewing a bunch of people who are
coming to a very elite college and say
you know what do you daydream about and
the one student said we don't daydream
about anything because it doesn't help
us to get into college and and you know
that's tragic it's a tragic issue for
that child but it's tragic for society
because it's those daydreams that
eventually lead to actual i i'll take
you know khan academy exists to a large
degree because my my boss at the hedge
fund in a very non-traditional for that
field had a strong belief in life work
about in in
balance and so i had time to daydream
about the khan academy i had time i had
and my wife was a resident a medical
resident so i i felt bad sitting and
vegging and watching tv um and so i was
able to
think about this uh this this problem
and and make resources and we and i
think anyone is capable of doing that we
just have to give them the time and and
the breathing room to do it especially
now since it appears i don't know if
this was in your book or
um
i heard it from tom friedman i mean most
of the jobs um of tomorrow are going to
be jobs that are going to be created not
jobs that currently exist yeah exactly
you know if you go you know the prussian
model
started with the industrial revolution
and the industrial revolution
we needed probably more educated people
than we needed kind of an agrarian
civilization you needed people who could
like read the directions and have the
discipline of the assembly line and all
of that
but there's also there's a certain
passivity that you also had to inculcate
you know in the farm there's a certain
independence and freedom to it all of a
sudden in a factory you're doing this
over and over again and you know and
we one can debate whether it was
explicitly done but there was an element
of instilling that passivity and an
indoctrination um
so that people could be good workers but
now we're in a reality you know before
the pyramid was like this you needed a
few knowledge workers who were doing
creative things and then you needed a
mass of of labor now the pyramids kind
of inverted where you we need a lot of
creative people in fact all of the real
careers now are creative focused and
open-ended and you need very few you
need very little physical labor and and
in that reality we're you know we're
training people for this while we need
you know we need the opposite right and
so since we are in the nation's capital
do you have any advice for congress or
the president how can they best help
bring this vision to life understanding
that yeah you know and this is it's an
interesting question because we do meet
with state officials and federal
officials and you know even in other
countries ministries of education and
the one thing that i don't want to
happen is you know right now it's been a
very grassroots grounds up thing people
have word of mouth khan academy people
have been using it parents have been
telling parents teachers have been
telling teachers
and that's good because that way these
are people who want to make it work and
they figure out and they tell us ways to
make it work better as soon as you make
it top down
i think it becomes
it
it becomes
no one likes it anymore and so we want
this to be very grassroots whatever i
tell people is just just tell people
about it tell people at minimum they
have a free tutor tell teachers that
look there might be another model that
you probably will enjoy more there are
ways to reach more students um and on
top of that and and i'm i'm serious
about this i i think it's a they should
set an example it's become too
it's too easy now in our society for
people saying oh i'm not good at math
and they'll say about like sixth grade
math oh i don't know that's math i don't
understand it no one will say oh i can't
read at a sixth grade level or if i
can't i can barely write no one says
that but people say you'll hear
politicians say that you'll hear ceo say
that you'll hear people in the in the
press say that and i think that
messaging should change and frankly the
only way that it could change is if they
directly engage with it i mean it's it's
shocking how many people are engaged in
education policy
where they don't know the subject matter
themselves they're like oh i'm not good
at math but this is how we should test
math math teachers it's like that's
crazy you yourself should engage in the
content or get it get a depth in the
content and that'll be a huge signal to
society and i think it'll also help help
inform policy and i think the more they
do that
they'll realize that it's a lot less
about top down a lot less about the
controls you know the controls that they
do every iteration of ed reform is just
about more controls on teachers and it
might
de-risk some of the the weaker players
but it also handicaps the
all the rest and so it kind of gets to
this kind of culture of you know
everyone getting to to mediocre and what
we need to really do is go the other way
have it be much more grassroots and what
i point out in this book that's an
american thing that we're we're a
country that's focused on creativity
we're a country that's focused on people
taking ownership over their lives but
our school system is a prussian one one
that's about passivity one that's about
authority and everything about this book
is let's make our school system more
american
yeah so any final thoughts
if you were sitting with president um
obama
you know at the white house aside from
asking him to use his bully pulpit more
i i'm somewhat serious about i would ask
him to
so this is a somewhat different
dimension but we talk about this in the
book
i would ask him to make content for us
because i think what's happening right
now is the public discourse gets so
disjointed in these 30 second sound
bites that you can't have a chance to go
deep on either side of
the aisle and right now you know the
main adult learning happens on the 24
hour news and it's in these 30-second
sound bites so no one really understands
the issues and it just becomes very
emotionally charged and this form factor
this way it's a chance for obama to
really explain
why he makes the decisions he does and
maybe the opposition to really explain
why and get to and diagram it out and
even have a quiz afterwards to make sure
that people are retaining it and it
would kind of fill in that gap in
learning that frankly people are crazy
some of our most popular videos are
about credit default swaps or the
healthcare plan or the difference you
know the electoral college these are
gaps in people's learning and adults of
any age want to learn that yeah well
it was a pleasure reading this book it
was nice meeting you thanks for joining
us oh it was a pleasure